our main story tonight concerns unions
the institutions that brought us the
weekend the middle class and in the case
of the international ladies garment
workers union an absolute banger of a
song and before we play this i have a
favorite singer here see if they're
yours too
[Music]
i mean they look so happy it's a video
so uplifting you barely pause to wonder
how many of them are dead now
and by the way yes my favorite singer is
the and run the house lady she's she's
the only one who gets to have a dramatic
entrance also she's got a fabulous
mushroom haircut wide lapels and the
voice of an angel every singer in that
song is a star but she is the brightest
in the galaxy
now that ad if it weren't obvious from
every single thing about it is from the
early 1980s and unfortunately since then
union membership has declined
considerably today just over 10 percent
of american workers belong to a union
that is just half the rate it was in
1983 meaning we're currently living in
one of the worst times for organized
labor in our country's history and it's
not like the demand isn't there nearly
half of non-union workers say they would
like to be in a union and a lot of
workplaces do seem like a natural fit
for one take amazon you've likely heard
the infamous stories of drivers for the
company being forced to pee in bottles
in order to make quotas stories that
amazon initially denied then apologized
for denying finally admitting that yeah
okay their drivers do sometimes have to
piss in bottles it's like the old adage
tis better to seek forgiveness than
permission unless this is about piss
bottles in which case take a look at
yourself man what are you even doing
mahatma gandhi
and yet despite that and other reports
of abysmal working conditions earlier
this year an organizing drive for amazon
warehouse workers in bessemer alabama
was voted down by more than two to one
which may seem like a clear-cut case of
workers deciding for themselves to
reject a union but the truth is it's a
lot more complicated than that because
if you have never been through a union
organizing drive yourself you might
assume that a union vote is a completely
free and fair election that is an
illusion fed by executives like jeff
bezos america's least inspiring
astronaut
through statements like this
we don't believe that we need a union to
be an intermediary between us and our
employees
but of course at the end of the day it's
always the employee's choice
and that's how it should be yeah i don't
know about you but i'm personally not
comforted by hearing one of the richest
men on earth say it's your choice no
matter the context all i can hear is
spear or arrow how would you prefer to
be hunted
it's your choice
but it is worth knowing just how many
ways amazon and many other companies try
to influence their employees choice
because they can exert a huge amount of
pressure so tonight let's take a look at
union busting what it is how it works
and how few consequences companies face
for doing it and let's start with a very
basic breakdown of how a union drive
works the first thing to know is that
any employer may recognize a union based
solely on majority support so they can
let employees unionize immediately but
they are not required to do that unless
it's been chosen through a secret ballot
vote so unsurprisingly that is how most
unions end up getting recognized and the
first key step in union busting is
preventing things from ever reaching
that point because for an election to
happen at all 30 of workers must sign a
union card expressing an initial
interest in union representation but
amazon for instance has instructed its
managers to be on high alert for the
slightest sign that that might happen as
this leaked internal video shows
if you see warning signs of potential
organizing notify your building hrm and
gm site leader immediately the most
obvious signs would include use of words
associated with unions or union-led
movements like living wage or steward
wow
i mean set aside how completely masked
off it is to treat the phrase living
wage like the first warning sign of a
stroke you would also think a nearly two
trillion dollar company like amazon
could spring for better animation than
jib jab
but
if enough workers do sign cards the
election process is then underway and in
that process companies have some pretty
huge advantages because obviously when
you're on their premises they have
unfettered access to you while also
having the ability to keep union reps
out and many companies take full
advantage of that access amazon for
instance inundated workers with
anti-union signs all over their
workplace even putting them inside
bathroom stalls they also use workers
contact info to send multiple anti-union
text messages to them per day and held
mandatory meetings that seemed designed
to spread fear
they had somebody who was like they're
the captain of the union busting who
would come down and teach like what was
the official title of the class they
just called it like union training
that's it which is funny because it's
not union training
it's anti it's union busting 101
right it's not union training if the
explicit goal is to kill the union it'd
be like taking a dog training class from
cruella de vil although no not the one
that's a misunderstood bohemian or
whatever i'm talking about the real
cruella yeah that one the original
doggie cycle bad
now
these mandatory propaganda sessions are
called captive audience meetings and
most amazon workers at bessemer were
having to attend at least two per week
and that is not uncommon nearly 90
percent of employers facing union
campaigns holds captive audience
meetings right now starbucks is facing a
union drive at six of its stores in
buffalo and it has been doing everything
that you've seen so far sending
anti-union text messages putting up
signs and holding captive audience
meetings and it may be no coincidence
that amazon's and starbucks tactics are
pretty similar because both hired union
busting law firms and consultants to
help them with their campaigns which is
not unusual union busting is a whole
industry there are about 2 000 of these
firms some of which have euphemistic
names like the labor relations institute
and 75 percent of companies facing
organizing drives hire one spending
nearly 340 million dollars on them per
year and these firms offer different
levels of services for companies on a
budget some offer mass-produced
anti-union videos you can even buy this
one featuring a cartoonishly overbearing
union organizer shot against a green
screen so that you can customize it
based on your workplace they even
produce samples of what that could look
like
listen just sign the card once a union
gets in you want to be on the good side
listen just sign the card once the union
well i'll say this at least they chose
outfits that would fit in any workplace
because we all know employees in both
corporate offices and warehouses dressed
like a college football coach whose wife
just left him and an america's next top
model contestant before the makeover
although the backdrops could clearly
have been more creative there you've got
a green screen the world is your oyster
why not show evil unionizers mobilizing
on a roller coaster or on a tropical
getaway or on the desert planet of
arrakis if you're gonna force employees
to watch your at least take
them on a cosmic journey with sandy soft
boy space jesus
but whether it is coming directly from a
company or through an outside firm
anti-union campaigns tend to follow a
pretty basic playbook and a go-to tactic
is to highlight that unions collect dues
it's a point that delta airlines made
when its employees were considering
unionizing and they did it in a pretty
dickish way
delta airlines causing a lot of
turbulence on the ground after it told
employees to buy video games instead of
unionizing one poster here it is as
union dues cost around 700 a year and
then tells employees to put their money
towards a video game system with the
latest hits
oh the latest hits you say
telling your workers to play video games
instead of unionizing is incredibly
condescending and doubly so when you
consider video game characters are the
ultimate example of exploited labor
think about it they take orders all day
usually get paid in coins and not once
in 36 years of playing mario have i ever
seen him get to take a bathroom break
not once
the mushroom kingdom has to be
absolutely littered with piss bottles at
this point
and you might say well of course a union
collects dues how else are they going to
have the resources to fight for their
members but these consulting firms will
insist that unions simply take money and
offer nothing in return here is how the
labor relations institute puts it in one
of its union busting videos unions are
in trouble
their membership is shrinking which
means they're in danger of going out of
business
they send out high pressure sales people
to sell a bill of goods that most people
believe is either of no real value or is
highly overpriced okay so just to be
clear that is a for-profit consulting
firm being paid by a for-profit company
arguing that unions are only in it for
the money that is
pretty fantastic it's not even the pot
calling the kettle black it's the pot
calling the kettle a pot it's it's like
being called a bad first date by ted
bundy now
lri consultants have also told employees
that joining a union might get them a
contract with less wages and less
benefits than they currently have but
think about how ridiculous that argument
is if companies genuinely thought unions
would negotiate worse terms for their
employees they'd be welcoming them in
with open arms jeff bezos would have
shown up to that interview in a che
guevara t-shirt if he thought it would
help him pay people less because the
truth here is unionized workers in the
private sector have wages about 25
higher than their non-union counterparts
that is why companies want to keep
unions out that is why they are willing
to pay lri three thousand dollars per
consultant per day but the anti-union
argument isn't just that they are
useless is that they'll destroy the
beautiful workplace culture that
companies have created here is how
targets framed it in one of their ud
busting videos
if the unions did try to organize target
team members they could also try and
bring along their way of doing business
an old-fashioned rigid structure no one
knows exactly what could happen but
there are lots of examples of how rigid
grocery store union contracts could hurt
our store's ability to serve guests
here's what we mean
[Music]
let's say you're working in stationary
but you're walking through domestics on
your way to check on something a guest
stops you and ask for help
what would you do
without even thinking about it you stop
and give them any assistance they
required
but what if union work rules say you
can't work outside of your department
what do you tell the guest
sorry i can't help you that makes you
look bad but more importantly it means
our guest doesn't get immediate
attention and they might not come back
so everyone gets hurt everyone except
the union oh
i like how they put that last part in
black and white so we know it's bad
we're talking can't open a jar bad
there's got to be a better way
but if i can just give the target
executives one quick note have you ever
worked retail because if you had you
would know that telling your floor
workers they'd be able to tell a
customer off this isn't my
department it's a pretty good argument
to vote yes on that union honestly
that might be worth it on its own
and from side note those aren't just
actors they're union actors members of
the screen actors guild in fact that man
later actually stressed in an interview
that he's very much pro-union defending
his appearance in the video by saying if
someone hires me to play a rapist does
it make me a rapist to which i have to
respond
what
and
i i guess not but uh
what
but the most frightening and effective
argument companies make against unions
isn't just that they'll keep you from
helping customers in other departments
is that they'll cost you your job now
thankfully it is against the law for
companies to threaten workers that if
they unionize their workplace will close
however hilariously it is legal for them
to predict the little shutdown which is
obviously not a real distinction when a
loan shark threatens to break your legs
that's not meaningfully different from a
loan shark predicting that legs will be
broken as a result of market forces
relating to lack of payment and that
prediction loophole can let a lot
through for instance columbia sportswear
brought in a consultant who freestyles
to a captive meeting of workers about
what could happen if they unionize
i've seen
the worst of it
doesn't always end up going so badly but
i mean i've seen people
you know just completely bankrupted
marriage is lost homes lost companies
posing
yes sometimes that happens to you i mean
look at look at detroit i mean
all the the auto workers there i mean uh
tens of thousands of employees lost
their jobs overnight
wow
that is a level of fear-mongering rarely
seen outside an abstinence-only sex ed
class don't join a union unless you want
to end up pregnant divorced homeless and
detroit
and it's not just colombia sportswear
when workers at a tire company called
kumho tried to unionize a few years back
12 different managers issued threats to
close the plant if the union won which
is undeniably scary and the thing is it
worked because even though 80 percent of
kumhar workers had initially signed
cards supporting unionization when the
vote happened less than a month later
only 43 percent voted to organize and
that is the thing
threats that a workplace will close are
effective despite being overwhelmingly
one study found 51 percent of
companies threatened to close plants if
unions won while just one percent
actually closed operations after a union
victory it is the same story again and
again and again and it can be
dispiriting for those who know just how
much good a union could do for their
co-workers listen to a woman who tried
to organize her nissan plant talk about
how it felt watching her union drive
fall apart
when we started this i i mean
my whole line was just
they were just yes but when they saw it
started bringing in those anti-union
videos
i've seen my co-workers just
that look on their face ms bitter i just
can't do it yeah and that is
heartbreaking and frustratingly even on
the rare occasion workers managed to
overcome everything that you have seen
tonight and win their election the fight
still might not be over as a study found
in a quarter of all successful union
elections getting a contract can take
three years or longer and while
companies are supposed to bargain in
good faith they can legally draw things
out to a ridiculous degree in 2009 some
texas employees at dish network voted to
unionize but over a decade later they
still have no contract and think about
how long ago 2009 was back then the kids
on modern family look like actual
children and at that point none of them
were engaged to the bartender from the
bachelor franchise in 2009 the question
on everyone's lips was is the guy from
degrassi really rapping now is he really
doing that and you really want me to
transport you back to that time i've got
two words for you susan boyle
remember how her whole thing was we
didn't expect someone who looked normal
could sing good the point here is 2009
was a long time ago and that is how
ridiculously long the employees of dish
network have been waiting for a fair
union contract and that actually brings
us to the final problem here because far
too often the consequences for
anti-union actions by companies are
minimal to none for instance companies
aren't supposed to retaliate against
workers who unionize but it happens all
the time take cynthia harper who worked
at a factory that made windshields after
she spoke up in favor of a union she had
a pretty sudden and pretty suspicious
change to her job ever since they
started this job it's been a two-man job
when they put me out here on it they
decided they wanted it to be a one
person's job
[Music]
when we talked to hr i told them they
were targeting me
put me on a job to set me up to write me
up for performance issues
and fire me
[Music]
okay that's pretty brazen isn't it they
took a job clearly for two people and
made her do it on her own and if you're
gonna set her up for failure why stop
there why not just give her everyone's
job why not send the entire factory home
with a note saying relax everyone
cynthia's got this and the thing is she
was right soon after that she was fired
along with two other pro-union
co-workers but the consequences for a
company doing that are just pathetic a
company that wrongfully terminates a
worker for supporting a union might be
forced to provide back pay but that on
its own is a pretty small price for them
to pay if it helps them crush a union
and other punishments are even weaker
like the fact that and this is true a
company can be ordered to post a notice
on the bulletin board in which it admits
that it violated the law but also and
this is crucial promises not to do it
again and cub on a company should
probably face more consequences for
illegally union busting than this dog
who clearly likes to hump this cat and
honestly in both cases i doubt the sign
is going to change the underlying
problematic behavior
so it is the wonder that us employers
are charged with violating federal law
in over 40 percent of all union election
campaigns because why wouldn't they
even when those charges are proven the
consequences are laughable one
anti-union consultant has flat out
stated what happens if you violate the
law the probability is you will never
get caught if you do get caught the
worst thing that can happen to you is
you get a second election and the
employer wins 96 of second elections and
it's not great that union busting firms
are telling companies that but it's even
worse that it's true
so what can we do here well congress
could step in to help rebalance the
playing field the protecting the right
to organize act or pro act would outlaw
captive audience meetings and enable
successfully unionized workforces to
seek arbitration to settle a first
contract meaning that companies like
dish can't give them the middle finger
for decades also and perhaps most
importantly it'll put real financial
penalties in place to prevent companies
from violating workers rights without
consequence but until that law is passed
and it should pass one of the most
important things for workers to do is to
try not to get disheartened during a
campaign which i know isn't easy but
union busting is all about killing
momentum splintering unity and
exhausting workers spirits so to the
extent that it helps if you're in a
workplace that's unionizing right now
and you're feeling pressured or
personally attacked remember the company
is almost certainly following a script
and you don't have to play the part that
they want you to and if by some chance
you're a corporate executive who's made
it this far into the show first
i'm almost impressed that you're still
here
but second please stop wasting money on
these anti-union consulting firms
instead just use this video that we made
for you it's a lot cheaper and it says
exactly what you really mean
[Music]
hello
thanks for joining us today and watching
this mandatory company video you're here
because someone may have approached you
about unionizing or ask you to sign a
union card or simply said the words
living wage out loud anywhere on company
grounds look a union may work for a lot
of places but the thing is here we're a
family and you employees are children
so let's listen in on some worker
conversations something we definitely
don't do in real life
hey bob did you know if we brought on a
union it'd be illegal for us to talk to
our bosses anymore no way there's two
things i love in this world talking
directly to my shift supervisor and
helping customers who are in departments
i don't work in well bad news bob if the
union came in you couldn't do that yeah
if a customer who's outside of your
department asks you a question you're
legally required to tell them to go
themselves
and if they ask you a follow-up question
you'd have to slap them with an open
hand
so everyone gets hurt everyone except
the union
wait how could the union possibly
benefit from something
we don't think a union is right for our
workplace but ultimately the choice is
always up to our employees we promise no
one will be fired for wanting to
unionize although there is a chance you
might be fired for poor attendance a
pretty good chance actually but you
won't be fired explicitly for the union
thing that's how we do it
for the next few weeks you might notice
a few extra posters around the workplace
in break rooms stock rooms
bathrooms
or glued to the back of a co-worker you
already went to the bathroom ted
these are just there to tell you things
like how expensive union dues are
seven hundred dollars think of what else
you could buy with that like a nintendo
wii with all the latest hits
or uh
i don't know what else do poor people
like
um
poor people
i know i've seen poor people
uh
the drugs
buy and eat drugs
did you know when a union enters a
negotiation or wages could go up or they
could go down wait our wages could go up
but they could go down realistically
they'll go up but they could go down but
without a union what's stopping them
from going down now but they could go
down right
just technically speaking
hey
i want to talk to you about your
attendance
just remember when it comes to unions
the choice is yours when it comes to
watching videos like this about unions
the choice is very much ours
did i say stop waving
[Music]
you